c'est une journée extrêmement précis
on s'installe dans la chambre on n'a pas
le goût d'en sortir
dans ma tête et aigle et c'était en
novembre 1961 christine riou âgé de 23
ans est forcé de mettre sa vie
d'enseignante sur pause atteinte de la
tuberculose
elle doit suivre un traitement à l'air
frais dans les grandes salles de kurdes
sanatorium de mont joli
[Musique]
face aux alternatifs aux affaires de la
thur la cus et à l'éclat au seo la salle
est accourue les livre est à tous dans
des sacs de couchage la haye en couche à
moi j'étais là parce que tout à viviez
vous l'avais dit aux puces a beau
jean des photographes amateurs à
documenter sa vie de tuberculeux au sein
de cette forteresse de la santé érigé en
1939 sur une colline qui surplombe le
fleuve saint-laurent pour limiter la
propagation de cette maladie mortelle
plus contagieuse que la coved 19 et les
tuberculeux était à l'image
d'aujourd'hui séparés de leur famille
est confiné je peux aller
le nettoyage de la vie il devait
respecter une routine strictes qui
consistait principalement en du repos et
au respect de bonnes habitudes d'hygiène
un couvre-feu était même imposé
la personne qui ressemblait plus à un
policier qu'autre chose
passé par toutes les chambres vérifiait
si nos fenêtres étaient ouvertes et
voyait à ce qu'on soit à nous d'abord le
sanatorium est en soi une petite société
il y avait un magasin général une caisse
populaire et même une salle de quilles
ou sous sol pour divertir les patients
et les travailleurs ont sur tempo on
avait tout ce qu'il nous fallait d'abord
ouais on avait une salle de jeu mais
qu'on pouvait jouer ok j'ai rencontré
mon mari là ok avec eux un pauvre
grappillage vaut pour lui aussi
des fois je dors le pij rêve à ça je
rêve que je suis rentré dans le petit à
petit je me promène d'un étage vikash
dans l'ascenseur que je veux pas me
faire part michel soucy a grandi sur la
côte du san
comme on l'appelle à mon julie son père
le médecin qui a mis sur pied le camion
de dépistage de la tuberculose qui
sillonnait les routes de la gaspésie et
de la côte-nord de village en village
c'est d'ailleurs sur ce camion qu'il
rencontra sa future épouse et je me
souviens j'étais tout petit le mais
c'était très impressionnant il y avait
toute une série de deux plaques
lumineuse pour lire les radios il y
régnait sur la côte du sable situées à
l'écart de la ville en réel esprit de
famille
le sentiment que j'ai aujourd'hui en
regardant ça c'était des gens qui
étaient très créatif et je pense que
c'était leur façon à eux de de
contribuer clairement lorsque la
pandémie a commencé j'ai pensé à son
histoire un peu plus de 80 ans plus tard
le petit fils du fondateur du sanatorium
de mont joli est sur la ligne de front
de la coved 19 lors de la première vague
de la pandémie c'est ce qu'on a vu un
les familles pouvaient pas pénétrer dans
les centres hospitaliers
j'ai eu beaucoup malheureusement déjà
qu'ils sont décédés seuls ils allaient
de leurs familles dont j'ai pensé à
cette analogie l'heure des gens qui
étaient isolés au sanatorium de mont
joli
tout comme les travailleurs du
sanatorium plusieurs de ses collègues
ont été isolés de leur famille au début
de la pandémie
on le vit qu'une ou comme
professionnelle la santé cette espèce de
stigmatisation que ouais on vous aime
vous êtes nos anges gardiens vous êtes
sur la première ligne mais reste loin
selon lui le québec attiré très peu de
leçons de l'épidémie de tuberculose
londres est que la cave il avait
toujours un pas ou de al avance de nous
et j'espère qu'on en tirera des leçons
pour le lait
amitié quand je suis sorti j'étais
décidé d'être une femme libre pour sa
part christine riou attirer de grandes
leçons ne sont pas sages au sanatorium
de mont joli
je vivais une vitesse assez incroyable
et j'ai diminué mais 10 pers
confiné pour une seconde fois dans sa
vie en raison de la coved
elle a une pensée pour les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui je crois que ces jeunes là
grâce à l'apport des mii auront une
autre pensée face à l'as dit et mandron
davantage dans tout ce qu'ils vont vivre
debout et de bon
[Musique]